foreign
is next in Lubbock Texas kicking off
this hour hi Yesenia how are you
I'm good how are you Dave better than we
deserve what's up
so um my husband has decided that we
should move up to Oregon Because he
believes the cost of living is lower and
would be able to get a better start we
currently do not have credit on a home
or anything like that so we've been
renting for the past three years
and so we're looking to buy a
fixer-upper home that our in my in-laws
would help us get and then you know
start paying off and such and it's about
40 40K and then to remodel and such we'd
invest about 60 possibly and currently
we owe about 10 in student loans and we
have 3 000 in savings that we could use
so considering we'd be moving about 1500
miles away we may need that to use to
move away or we may you know so paying
off our student loans right now I'm not
sure if that would be the wisest
decision and then we also have a about
30 000 in our car loan
good Lord that we just took out
there's a lot going on in this call what
uh what's your household income
it's about 40 to 60k a year but my
husband has potential to make more
because he has his CDL for Trucking
and his family
is an organ
yes
okay
uh so so you're asking me what
so what would you recommend do you think
it would be a wise thing to to move in
this current situation that we're in and
with our savings nope
you guys aren't going to like me and
you're probably not going to do what I
tell you to do but you're gonna wish you
did you don't need to buy a fixer-up
upper when you're broke people
it's going to cause you problems
he's got this dream in his head that if
he can just get closer to family this is
all going to work out cost of living in
Oregon and Lubbock Texas is not any
different that's absolute BS
you're not you don't live in a high cost
of living area darling
he found his daddy or his mom I found a
fixer-upper and he's got the bug to move
back home that's where how all this is
going well he's dreaming all this up
while he's around while he's driving
truck
he's sitting thinking about it all day
while he's grinding gears so no it's I
got to tell you please don't do this
it's going to be a mess
and so what would I do if I were in your
shoes I'd work like six jobs I'd sell a
stupid car you just bought get you a car
you can afford that's absolutely
ridiculous purchase
and then I'd get those debts paid off
and once the debts are paid off I'd pile
up some money and then if you want to
make a move make a move and pay cash for
the little Fixer-Upper or go up there
and rent until you can pay cash for the
little fixer-upper
right but there is no cost of living
move from Lubbock to Oregon
all right how long have you been are you
working and how long has he been driving
the truck with the CDL what's going on
there
he's been Trucking about a year and I
have my degree in in biology so I could
use that to teach or to continue my
education the goal is to be to go and be
an EMT for the meantime so that I'm
generating income
when are you doing that
EMT would be in about would be at in
January why
this is July when the program would
start
what are you gonna do between now and
then
or I can look to start in September
that's what I know you got to be working
you guys can knock this out ten thousand
dollars in student loan debt you can
knock that out quickly what's the car
worth
the car I think it's worth about what we
paid I think it was worth like two to
three thousand more than what we paid
yeah get out of that now please get out
of that
it was a huge mistake
is that not just does that not just have
red lights on top of it flashing at you
going
error error error
I definitely had lost a lot of sleep
over the debt for sure yeah yeah and
then we just added a big old pile to it
just for the fun of it because we wanted
to go buy a car so we need to slow down
and develop
step-by-step plans to clear debt build
cash then move then build cash before we
buy
okay so you think it'd be a very foolish
decision to move across the country
almost 100 sure
I'm a hundred percent sure it'd be very
foolish for you to move across the
country the way you just described it to
me
absolutely I kind of thought it was a
bit far
ther he's down here my husband would
just not be home at all so that's kind
of why I've been a stay-at-home mom for
the past year and a half and also
because of the cost of child care for me
to be a biology teacher which is all I
have right now so what's keeping him
what's keeping him from getting that
better job just that it's not ideal for
the family
I think so but I really pray he would
just have the wisdom to take that step
I've tried telling him that that's what
husbands have to do it's the next step
for them to be providing and taking care
of the family and it's not always
comfortable I would love for him to be
home but that's not where we're at
financially or with you know starting
out our new lives and well what if it's
a season a home what if it's a season
for a period of time if it takes you
guys sell a car if it takes you guys a
year to get your finances straightened
up so you can move then all of you go to
work and let's get moving that's right
everybody pays a price let's get this
moving and then then head off to Oregon
I'm not mad at Oregon okay you can go uh
but you know he's got this all dreamed
up that he's gonna you know what we have
is a mess and then let's go ahead and
buy a house that's a mess
and add a mess to a mess
that that's just you're just you're
signing up for Terror
no thank you the harder he works you
send you the faster you get to Oregon
that would be the vision I would try to
cast with him now right after we sold
the car oh yeah
did I mention you need to sell that car
I hope I was clear about that